if you ask for the hazelnut pump with
whipped cream on top that is a birthday
cake culata
and
[Music]
my name is tilani i'm from jersey city
and i'm a former duncan employee
hi my name is liz and i'm a former
starbucks barista
oh the worst drink someone's ever
ordered oh this is my favorite
there was this woman who got a grande
cup
and she wanted 10 pumps of
white mocha 10 pumps of vanilla
syrup and then she just wanted whole
mouth i
i was shocked i had to clarify but i do
remember it being like maybe six in the
morning
when she ordered this this one person
will order um onion bagel
with strawberry cream cheese and i just
think that sounds nasty to me
oh and then there was another one who
this woman used her
free drink points to get a venti
hot cup filled with espresso shots it
was over
30 shots of espresso that we put in
almost didn't want to make it because i
was nervous
are we gonna get in trouble fools i just
don't know
but you know the customer's always right
so we did this
and when she left i just looked at my
co-worker and i was like did we just
did we just murder someone
[Music]
i think just talking and i guess being
cute my male co-workers if they found a
you know a girl cute or something they
might give her like a free
donut or a free thing on the end
i would probably go around like
10 a.m because the likelihood of there
being a huge line
is fairly slim there's a early morning
rush because people want it
right before they're going to work like
oh like i need my coffee
then lunch time everyone comes in so i
want to say
anytime afternoon anytime before 7
30.
[Music]
definitely frappuccinos it takes some
time and then if you're following the
protocol
like we can only make one frappuccino
in the blender at once yeah i mean that
just slows you down
any drink that you want to have like
this amount of sugar this amount of this
go inside because if you're doing that
through drive-through do not expect it
to actually be what you ask for because
no one's really paying attention to that
like
we're doing like what we can't
[Music]
if you like vanilla try they have like
frozen vanilla chop
ten of ten thousand out of ten like the
best thing ever
one of my favorite food items is the
grilled cheese
is it overpriced maybe will i get it
anyway
yes also if you like birthday cake you
basically just ask for a vanilla bean
culata but ask for hazelnut pump if you
ask for the hazelnut pump with whipped
cream on top that is a birthday cake
culada
and
i know that there has never been one
we have no idea what you're talking
about so just
tell us what's in it and we're gonna do
our best
there's no secret menu but
people kind of would have like their own
kind of custom things there was this
couple who asked me for a grasshopper
frappuccino
i had no idea what that entailed
and they didn't either so i just made a
matcha
frappuccino with some mocha drizzle
and i was like there you go it's green
and you have mocha because
your grasshopper's in the dirt
[Music]
okay at the end of the night if there's
a lot of donuts we
literally would have people sometimes
come in or even wait outside
to get like a free donut because you
know like if there's some at the end of
the night like we're not gonna always
carry them over
the most annoying thing is can i have a
free donut can i have a free donut
oh like you're probably going to throw
this away anyway like let me get this
for free blah blah blah blah blah
that's annoying
when i was cleaning up like our lobby
when i was walking
this guy asked me to marry him that's
just kind of creeped me out
i used to just be asked like crazy
things especially regarding my hair
like i would have like my like kind of
afro and i just remember this one guy he
would always make comments about my hair
he'd be like
oh i hope i don't find a one of those
hairs up in my coffee today
that's the that's like a bad experience
that i had from a customer
and then there was this other guy i was
doing our display case so i was like
filling it
and he grabbed my hand and then said
it's as soft as i thought it would be
you need to be patient with baristas
okay because we're trying our hardest so
be kind be patient and you'll probably
get a better drink that way
be nice to your baristas also if you
tip in like the tip jar we actually get
it we split it
people often are like they want their
coffee and they want it now
and like we're like in 10 different
places back there it may seem like oh
we're just
i don't know chilling or whatever you
may think but be a little bit more
nice patient slow down when you say your
order
saying it fast does not we don't it
doesn't make us
make it any faster slow down you know
help us help you make the coffee the
best it can be
[Music]
you